there's a new service it's called Cupid
dot me and it's a free website that lets
users text and share their verified STD
information so it's basically a giant
database of what do you have so ain't
gotta really Midea
me another STD not everything here's the
thing I hope it's not and I was like
okay this is kind of dope first of all
kind of kills the mood when someone's
like yo like you're about to get down
they're like let me see the app that
will show you that do it before you go
on the right to say what your Facebook
stock that you like you know it but
first of all I'm gonna be at some STD
database either way because who knows if
I screw it up and suddenly I'm like aids
girl because I'm going screwed something
up okay but the second part is this app
only shows four things that are very
testable which are chlamydia gonorrhea
syphilis and HIV herpes and warts which
are extremely more rampant and terrify
me and are permanent and will never go
away are not part of this app so
somebody's like you I don't have
chlamydia I'm like who cares you could
take like a pill for that I want to know
if you comfy that terrifies me I feel
like this app does nothing for me if
they're not broken out they can still
great if you have chlamydia like so what
you probably could take a pill and that
could go away there's waste scarier
things out there this app does not cover
it we're an inherent problem with an
opt-in STD app you know you mean like
only a certain level of people I it
could be people that are trying to be
honest but the point of the site of
opting in the point of this is not that
people aren't gonna be able to take
advantage obviously if somebody it has a
disease and they don't want to share
that and they want to have sex
regardless this app is not good that's
not the point of it I think the point of
this is to be able to avoid that awkward
conversation right like early on like if
people are just wanting to have you know
safe casual sex between two consenting
adults have fun it's not a relationship
it's not whatever you hang out one time
you want to be able to hook up it's a
little awkward to be like okay so let me
see your staff yeah I think that was the
point I made it in a terrible way was I
was trying to say is generally and
hopefully if it's somebody that you're
having a one-time casual sexual
experience with you're going to use a
condom whether you're trying to prevent
disease or pregnancy or whatever I'm not
judging people that do verse don't
choose whatever you'd like what I'm
saying is the thing on this particular
STD app only has things that are
preventable by condom so a test for
chlamydia stuff
let's gonorrhea and HIV which are the
things that condoms protect for and the
one thing it can't show you is whether
somebody has herpes or Wars or multitude
of other things or HPV which are other
things they're completely can get while
still using a condom so many useless HPV
for example basically like 80% of people
about 1/3 have an active viral outbreak
right now and almost all men don't don't
even know they have it
they don't even know for us there is a
stick something at home where everything
that we're all being techies here as
we've been talking about but to me this
is one of the few things that actually
strikes me as negative and it also it
just it just lends itself to lying and
disconnecting the sex like that it's
such it doesn't go well somebody and all
your feelings the other person doesn't
they can spread this and stop it I want
to be in some database where there could
be a mistake I don't want any Delta be
like oh look at Jen up and she's in the
chlamydia database you'd be like what
the hell do you like verified cheque
yeah if I like Twitter Honoria yeah hear
it it's like that's so personal well you
want to know there's this app called STD
triage you can take a picture of your
genitals if you think you have herpes or
worth's or something and they're looking
like you send it to them and then
somebody will diagnose you which is
strange to diagnose somebody a through
an iPhone and I I knew that that's
actually a really really good we can
help people who can't email any pictures
are there cooter through the internet
like might have hurt be send well let's
say that you're a reader for Barry I by
the way that's my favorite scandal
wiener game but let's say you're a very
very poor person who thinks that they
were recently exposed to your who's
really scared not able to get through
the day obviously there are free clinics
around but they don't have
transportation there there are many
reasons why exactly and so so I think
that that is actually just another kind
of option
yeah individual it's helpful just scares
me that people may think they I don't
know who's on the other end of it they
didn't make it very clear who's
diagnosing it so somebody who may be
carrying something they could say oh no
that just looks like you know you got a
bad bikini wax and they're like I'm cool
yeah
almost every time it would say something
like that's something you should be
getting all right clearly the theme of
the show has been sort of a distrust of
people and governments and they trust
for science and rational thought and an
own your own body all right I'm gonna
let you two this was the fastest show I
think that we ever did here I'm gonna
let you guys pimp yourselves out you can
talk directly to camera number three
okay well I'm one of the newest members
of The Young Turks so see me on The
Young Turks more often on the main show
on the point on lots of of the sideshows
I also recently oh gosh there's so much
okay I know sorry I'm sorry just check
out my website Cara Santa Maria calm or
Twitter at Cara Santa Maria and you'll
see everything there hello let me go saw
related the camera here's where you can
find me I'm just kidding um so basically
the easiest way to find me is on Twitter
which is just at Jenn Hoffman je and an
H o FF ma n or my website and my blog
and my about me and my whole spiel and
links to other stuff is on Jen Hoffman
dot-com there you go and you guys know
you can find me at Rubin report on
Twitter I thank you guys for watching